avec moi sur ce plateau elena volochine
bonjour bonjour monsieur vous êtes là
chef de notre bureau à moscou et c'est
l'heure de la chronique vu d'aussi
alors l ena vous avez signé à ce
reportage et vous avez décrypter pour
nous comment la propagande russe
façonnent ce soutien des russes à
vladimir poutine oui nous sommes lundi
hier soir il y avait à la télévision
russe l'émission vestine idier les sur
l'une des deux principales chaînes de
télévision rossiya 1 c'est une
hebdomadaire présentée par dimitri qui
sell-off une star parmi les stars de la
propagande russe son émission est dans
le top 5 des émissions les plus
regardées en russie 18 % de part
d'audience pour la précédente édition
celle du 20 mars alors hier soir et les
19 heures à paris 20h à moscou bienvenue
dans la réalité parallèle voici les
titres
des milliers de citoyens pacifiques
utilisée par les nazis comme boucliers
humains tout va bien on se bat pour la
bonne cause pourquoi l'occident a choisi
l'ukraine comme champ de bataille avec
la russie l'ukraine a toujours été la
pierre angulaire
cette ville historique
et comment se dope résidents aisés les
niches
continue de cirer les centres des
gouvernements occidentaux
[Musique]
alors voilà trois titres qui martèlent
les postulats de base diffusés à
longueur de journée par la propagande
russe ces postulats qui participent à un
forget chez les russes cette idée que la
russie est dans une guerre juste contre
le mal forget est répandue par
l'occident en ukraine titre un des nazis
ukrainiens se servent de civils comme
boucliers humains et des soldats russes
ont le moral au plus haut parce qu'il se
bat pour la bonne cause titre 2 c'est
bien l'occident qui a provoqué cette
guerre en ukraine pour attaquer la
russie et immédiatement on a un
politologue qui précise que l'occident
ce sont les américains l'ennemi de
toujours qui sont à la manoeuvre et puis
de metric et c'est love sort les grands
mots russophobie nazis le mal absolu
donc puisque non seulement ce sont des
nazis mais en plus ils haïssent les
russes et tout ça se passe sur la terre
slave la terre slave c'est très
important comme référence pour faire
surgir finalement chez les russes ce
sentiment que ces nazis russophobe il
viendrait nous et zac est chez nous
alors vous me direz mais l'ukraine ce
n'est pas chez les russes mais justement
cette propagande et veille le sentiment
pour les russes que l'ukraine c'est leur
terre cette terre slave que des nazis
russophobe à la botte des états unis
chercheraient à occuper voilà pourquoi
les russes d'ailleurs parle de
libération n'est ce pas et voilà ce qui
crée maintient ce fameux sentiment dont
on parle beaucoup de forteresse assiégée
il y à cette conception fondamentale
d'une nounou slave par opposition à
l'occident et demi est seul on en vient
au troisième point à savoir que
l'ukraine dans cette histoire n'a pas
droit de cité en tant qu'etat et devrait
revenir à la russie et non aux
américains d'où le troisième titre de
ces titres qui ridiculise un zelensky on
entendu pseudo président qui cirent les
pompes des parlements européens tout ça
pour dire que c'est un président un
poster puisque son pays lui même est une
imposture c'est ce que pense et ce que
dit vladimir poutine que l'ukraine en
tant que nation est une erreur de
l'histoire alors l ena en trois titres
on a véritablement une réécriture
historique oui à la propagande diffusée
par dmitri kessel of elle passe aussi
par de grandes leçons civilisationnel
qu'il fait au cours de son émission dans
cet autre extrait il parle par exemple
de restaurer la grandeur de la russie il
joue sur ses sentiment revanchard des
russes qui auraient été selon la
propagande reléguée au second plan par
un occident impérialiste après la chute
de l'union soviétique écouter
l'époque où une version d'illusions
quant à l'eau jean est révolu à cannes
celle là proche ou d'un côté c'était
réconfortant mais de l'autre les
sanctions croissante l'extension
militaires de l'otan dans notre
direction le refus des pourparlers sur
la sécurité et la frange préparation à
la destruction militaire de la russie
ont fait qu'il était impossible de
rester passif face à ce qui se passe non
pas six mais nos bleus janeiro a presque
radiations alors ce dimitri qui sied
love c'est carrément un idéologue oui il
faut parler un peu de lui parce que ce
n'est pas n'importe qui d'abord il est
sous sanctions de l'union européenne
pour son soutien évidemment ouvert à
l'annexion de la crimée mednick ricky
sell-off n'en est pas moins n'en est
rien moins que le directeur de l' agence
de presse internationale
rossiya simonian ans rue ça veut dire
russie aujourd'hui russia today rt si ça
vous dit quelque chose créé en décembre
2013 en pleine révolution de maidan en
ukraine l' agence de presse
internationale aussi à civaux n'ya était
destiné englober plusieurs médias
étatiques russe dont l' agence de presse
russe ria novosti mais aussi les chaînes
de télévision multilingue russia today
donc perte est devenu plus tard rt et l'
agence de presse spoutnik margarita
simonienne la rédactrice en chef de rtl
mais directrice de la rédaction de cette
grande agence de presse internationale
et il s'agissait donc l'un en 2013 de
l'ouverture d'un front informationnel
multilingue pour étendre la propagande
russe en occident et notamment en france
et je rappelle qu'en union européenne ou
après l'invasion d'ukraine rts pique
nique ont été interdits en 2015 mitri
qui se lovent que j'avais interviewé à
l'époque me disait on ne gagne pas une
guerre si on n'a pas d'abord gagner la
guerre de l'information et dans cette
guerre de l'information que même la
russie il est très important de faire
comprendre aux russes que c'est
l'occident qui a besoin de la russie et
non pas la russie qui a besoin de
l'occident écoutez cet autre extrait de
l'émission d'hier soir
vive le père français deux livres les
mêmes seuils oral et a posté ces
derniers temps en europe on parlait sans
cesse de renoncer au gaz russe à
économiser on va baisser un peu le
chauffage dans les appartements ont pas
ralentir sur les autoroutes on va
économiser
l'autonomie que l'on respire de chaque
bout du môle et au final tout ce
discours n'était qu'un mensonge
irresponsable en europe il n'y a plus de
politique écologique il n'y a eu peur
panique est rare que faire sans le gaz
russe
obtient ce qu'il veut nos styles et à
soyaux alors ce digne dimitri qui si
elle offre il est aussi connu pour ses
diatribes contre les homosexuels et ses
relents antisémites
oui notez que c'est quand même
malheureux lorsque l'on prétend être en
guerre contre les nazis mais
effectivement qui s'élève à eu cette
phrase notamment il faudrait enterrés ou
brûler leur coeur comme impropres à
perpétuer la vie il parlait là des
homosexuels morts dans les accidents de
la route et dont les organes donc serait
impropre au don d'organes la propagande
russe elle joue aussi beaucoup sur ces
valeurs conservatrices et traditionnels
russes qui serait elle aussi menacée par
un occident décadent et des russes avec
qui je parle et qu'on dit son beef y ait
par la propagande n'est ce pas me disent
même mais si on ne fait pas la guerre ou
en ukraine aujourd'hui on aura demain
des gays européen qui viendront nous
envahir et nous imposer leurs valeurs
alors il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur
cette émission sur tous ces messages
parce qu'elle dure plus de trois heures
et ce n'est qu'une émission parmi toutes
celles qui sont qu'il se déverse à
longueur de journée sur les chaînes de
télévision russes mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'il y à cette
construction constante est à la fois
complexes d'un sentiment de peur à la
fois face à l'ennemi et d'un sentiment
aussi de revanche vis-à-vis de cet
ennemi qui viendrait nous attaquer et
donc cette position défensive pour dire
in fine et que la russie n'a pas attaqué
mais elle défend en ukraine merci
beaucoup et léna wolverine pour votre
éclairage sur la propagande d'état